اخيرا وبعد اسابيع انهت واشنطن اليوم
انتشار حطام المنفاذ الصيني الذي اسقط
قبيله الساحل الشرقي لامريكا لكن ماذا بعد
القطعه الاخيره من الحطام ستنقل الى
المختبر التابع لمكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
في فرجينيا من اجل التحقيق وهنا سيتم
معرفه ان كان منطاد استخدم للتجسس ام لا
بكين تنفي طبعا وتقول انه مدني لكن قصه
المنطاد فتحت الباب امام امر اخر اجسام
غريبه في السماء في عدد من الدول ومنها
امريكا وكندا وحتى الصين خلال الاسبوع
الحالي فقط رصدت ثلاثه اجسام غريبه في
اجواء امريكا الشماليه حتى اسقطتها
الطائرات الامريكيه ولا تعلم واشنطن بعد
ماهيتها لكن مقابل اتهامات واشنطن لبكين
هناك اخرى بالعكس مناطيض امريكيه دخلت
المجال الجويه الصيني اكثر من عشر مرات
منذ يناير من العام الماضي
قدموا لنا تفسير وهدم ما تريده اقدم لنا
تفسير هذا ما تريده الصين من امريكا كل
هذه الاتهامات المتبادله ومنها طبعا ما له
علاقه بالتجسس لكن قائد القياده الشماليه
كان له راي اخر وخارج الصندوق الخارج
الكوكب
بعد الجدل الذي اثاره تصريح قائد القياده
الشماليه الامريكيه
الجنرالندي بانه لا يستبعد بان تكون
الاجسام المجهوله التي اسقطتها القوه
الامريكيه مؤخرا قادمه من خارج الكوكب اكد
البيت الابيض انه ليس هناك اي مؤشر على
انشطه لكائنات فضائيه خلال عمليات اسقاط
الاجسام الثلاثه لكن الجدل حولها مستمر
سياسيا فالجمهوريون صعدوا من انتقادهم
لتاخر الرئيس بايدن باسقاط المنطاد الصيني
كما انتقدوه ايضا في موضوع الاجسام
المجهوله لتاخره بتوجيه خطاب للامريكيين
لشرح ما حصل وحاولت الاداره الامريكيه
تهدئه احباط اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ بشان
المنطاد ونقص المعلومات حول الاجسام
المجهوله بتقديم احاطه سريه لاطلاعهم على
اخر تطورات لكن معظم الاعضاء خاصه
الجمهوريين خرجوا من الاحاطه باسئله اكثر
من المعلومات كما قالوا ليبقى الغموض يلف
الاجسام المجهوله